terrible situation it's never been
anything like this one of the most
important issues in battling this
pandemic is coordinating the delivery of
the crucial supplies throughout the
nation based upon the most accurate
information available and we've got the
best health care and disaster experts
anywhere in the world and everybody will
tell you that and we're dealing with big
parts of the world on helping them also
through this horrible situation where
151 still 151 nations are going through
it or working to ensure that the
supplies are delivered where and when
they're needed in some cases were
telling governor's we can't go there
because we don't think you need it and
we think someplace else needs it then
pretty much so far we've been right
about that and we'll continue to do it
as it really gets this will be probably
the toughest week between this week and
next week and there'll be a lot of death
unfortunately but a lot less depth death
than if this wasn't done but there will
be death we're looking for an obvious
focus and the hardest hit regions some
of them are obvious and some aren't so
obvious they spring up they come and
they they hit you like you got hit by a
club an area that wasn't at all bothered
you look at what's going on in New
Jersey the governor is doing an
excellent job by the way but how that
sprang up every decision that were made
that we're making is made to save lives
it's really our sole consideration we
want to save lives we want as few lives
lost as possible it's therefore critical
that certain media outlets stop
spreading false rumors and creating fear
and even panic with the public it's just
incredible I could name them but it's
the same ones always the same ones and I
guess they're looking for ratings I
don't know what they're looking for so
bad for our country and so bad the
people understand it you look at the
levels and approval ratings and they're
the lowest they've ever been for media
it's so bad for four
our country so bad for the world you
know put it together for a little while
get this over with and then go back to
your fake news during a national
emergency it's just essential that the
federal decision-makers cut through the
fog of confusion in order to follow the
facts and the science many hospital
administrators that we've been in touch
with even in the really hot spots you
know what they are communicating
directly with us that their level of
supplies are meeting essential needs and
at the current time they're really
thrilled to be where they are
whenever local shortages are reported
we're asking States to immediately meet
the demand and we're stockpiling
large amounts in different areas in
different areas that we're going to be
discussing that in a little while but we
want distributions to be made on a fair
basis we have to take care of a large
country not just certain areas of the
country but no matter where we're we've
been there and we've been there very
strongly I want to thank FEMA I want to
thank the Army Corps of Engineers I want
to thank our military for what they're
doing and we're going to be adding a
tremendous amount of military to help
supplement the state's thousands of
soldiers salves thousands of medical
workers professionals nurses doctors and
it'll be a large number it'll be we'll
be telling them over the next verse
short period where they're going they're
going into war they're going into a
battle that they've never really trained
for nobody's trained for this nobody's
seen this I would say since 1917 which
was the greatest of them all the
greatest of this type of battle probably
the greatest of them all right 1917 up
to a hundred million people were killed
in addition we're working directly with
hospitals and existing suppliers and
distributors to ensure that those with
the greatest need are prioritized and
that need changes one day it's one state
or one locale one city and then all of a
sudden they start
to do well we had some very good reports
coming out of the state of Washington
coming out of various parts of
California so areas that we were getting
ready to really hit hard we can now go
to other areas it looks like New York is
going to be hit very hard and Louisiana
is just amazing the way it just spread
up and everyone's doing a good job but
they're gonna be hit hard areas in the
country that are not experiencing
large-scale infections are requesting
supplies beyond what their present
circumstances require and we talked to
them what we tell them and we explain it
and for the most part they're good with
it we think we're right it's very
understandable that officials would seek
to get the most they can get for their
communities but the fears of the
shortages have led to inflated requests
we have some states and areas where
they're just asking for far more me look
we had one state asking for 40,000
ventilators 40,000 think of it
40,000 it's not possible they won't need
that many and now they're admitting they
don't need that many but we're getting
as many as we can to them again nobody's
ever seen anything like this in terms of
ventilators in terms of protective
equipment and uniforms and outfits but
it makes it more difficult for
distributors to prioritize the real need
and it could intentionally and you know
look they have everybody has proper
intentions but they want to make sure
they're 100% and sometimes when they
know they don't need it they want it
anyway it gives them that extra feeling
of satisfaction but we just can't do
that it's not even possible to think
about and that's why and we're back up
remember we're a backup we're the
greatest backup that ever existed for
the states especially when we start
getting into the hospital building
business and getting into the medical
center building business when you see we
built many hospitals numerous hospitals
in some states and medical centers
that's why my administration's been
requesting action
usage numbers directly from the states
and hospitals to meet their needs
because we want to be ready when when
the brunt of it comes which is coming
quickly you see it you see it assures
you can see it and when the brunt of it
comes we want to be ready to hit the
area that needs it
we don't want to have spent everything
in one area and they don't need it there
then it where near the extent so let me
be extremely clear about one point we
will move heaven and earth to safeguard
our great American citizens we will
continue to use every power every
authority every single resource we've
got to keep our people healthy safe
secure and to get this thing over with
we want to finish this war we have to
get back to work
we have to get we have to open our
country again we have to open our
country again we don't want to be doing
this for months and months and months
we're going to open our country again
this country wasn't meant for this if
you were if you were but we have to open
our country again I just spoke with the
commissioners leaders of I would say
virtually all of the sports leagues Rob
Manfred Commissioner of baseball Major
League Baseball Roger Goodell
Commissioner of the National Football
League Adam Silver Commissioner of the
National Basketball Association Gary
Bettman Commissioner of the National
Hockey League Jay Monahan Commissioner
of the PGA Tour kathy Engelberg
commissioner of the Women's National
Basketball Association Dana White the
Ultimate Fighting Championship Vince
McMahon president of the WWE Don Garber
Commissioner of Major League Soccer
Steve Phelps president of NASCAR Michael
Wong Commissioner of the LPGA Roger
Penske founder and chairman Penske Corp
Andrew Fleming president of the Breeders
Cup and there are a couple of others on
and these are all the great leaders of
sport
and they want to get back they got to
get back they can't do this their sports
weren't designed for it the whole
concept of our nation wasn't designed
for we're gonna have to get back we want
to get back soon very soon for example
and I have to say we're using the
defense production act very powerfully
in some guys times directly in many
cases indirectly just the threat of it's
usually enough but FEMA and HHS have
ordered a hundred and eighty million
think of that one hundred and eighty
million who ever heard of a hundred and
eighty million in 95 masks and we're
working now with 3m to see whether or
not that all works out but we want them
to help our country and I think it's
going to be okay we're gonna soon let
you know but we need the masks we don't
want other people getting and that's why
we're that's why we're instituting a lot
of defense production act you could call
it retaliations because that's what it
is it's a retaliation if people don't if
people don't give us what we need for
our people we're going to be very tough
and we've been very tough usually we
don't have to use it but we've used it
plenty it's turning out more and more
unfortunately and it works very well our
supply supply chain logistics task force
led by Admiral John Paul of check who's
doing a fantastic job will ensure
they're distributed to the health care
and critical infrastructure workers in
the areas with the most pressing
requirements that's the 60 million masks
that we're talking about and the hundred
and one hundred and eighty million n95
masks hundred and eighty million who
ever heard of a hundred and eighty may
in masks and this is a incredible thing
a lot of times that we have to stop play
this game if a governor wants 200
ventilators and I say no we're going to
send you a thousand we think you need
more than 200 and then the media meets
with the governor and they say oh you
got more well it's not enough the
president should have sent more so he's
asking for 200 we give him a thousand
they say how's the president doing he
should have given more because it's
politics that's politics and that's
unfortunate because we can't play that
game and you know that's one party doing
it did the other parties happy but
they're all really happy because they
should have been doing this work
themselves for a long period of time
many of their cupboards were bare with
respect to the ventilators FEMA and HHS
continue to monitor the data on an
hourly basis
we're provided by the states in order to
most effectively target the distribution
of supplies we've been asking States to
provide us with daily updates on the
number of ventilators and their
utilization rates because some states
have more ventilators than they need did
anyone like to admit it they'll admit it
when everything's over but that doesn't
help us very much
this data is vitally necessary so that
we can ensure our ventilators are
getting to the right place at the right
time FEMA HHS DoD are developing
resources within the next 24 hours they
will have a whole different set of
criteria every day it's different
criteria every day this horrible
invisible enemy changes of course it
changes course if you were fighting the
normal fight you know what's happening
here's they hit one they hit another
they had another state they hit areas
that you didn't expect but we're
watching it and we're capturing it our
goal is to stay several days ahead of
the needs in each state but we can only
do that if the cities and states utilize
real-time local knowledge to
by timely and precise data about actual
usage so we have to be able to do that
and if a state has ventilators as an
example that they know they're not going
to need they should give them over or we
should move them with the other ones we
have now 10,000 in our pipeline and
stockpiled 10,000 close and we're moving
some into New York so gonna need some
additional we're moving some into New
York City and State separately and we're
bringing them to the point where they'll
need them I can also report that at my
direction 1,000 military personnel are
deploying to New York City to assist
where they're needed the most that's the
hottest of all the hotspots New Jersey
is right there it's right next to it and
I don't know if that's overflow but New
Jersey's it's a great state and it's a
very to crowded state also where you
have people on top of people it's always
tough but we're bringing some of the
ventilators we got some for New Jersey
just yesterday and we're gonna bring
them some more including doctors we're
getting doctors nurses respiratory
specialists and other support workers
these are from the military we're taking
people now out of our military we've
been doing it but now we're doing it on
a larger basis and I want to thank
Secretary of Defense Esper who will
detail some of what we're doing tomorrow
and Monday as a situation in Washington
state continues to stabilize we're
returning a 300 bed federal medical
station to a different location so well
we need it and we appreciate that they
won't be needing it and we appreciate
them letting us know we're going to move
it to a different location who's already
built many governors initially made
large requests for federal support for
their states and anticipation of a
greater number of cases but the
residents of Washington State have done
a really good job of following the
federal distancing guidelines they
really have I'm also pleased to report
that our agon will be spending and
sending they're spending a lot of money
because they really did stockpile well
and they're also sending
a hundred and forty ventilators directly
to New York which we appreciate and I
want to thank the vice president for the
great work he's doing every day dealing
with our nation's governor's Mike Pence
has been working day and night on this
and we want to get it over he's got to
get a little more sleep than he's
getting he hasn't been getting very much
I will tell you that and we're all in
this together and it's a beautiful thing
to see how people are joining forces to
help one another if they really are in
addition to our courageous doctors
nurses and health care workers I also
want to thank the incredible food supply
workers who are feeding our nation I
spoke just a little while ago to Senator
Boozman you know Senator Boozman we all
do is a great senator is a great person
we spoke just this morning and we
discussed how important it is to keep
our farmers and ranchers processes and
distributors in our nation's prayers and
I want to thank the senator for the
incredible job he's been doing and a lot
of the senators and congressmen and
everyone everybody's working very hard
my administration is working very
aggressively to pioneer new medical
countermeasures to treat and prevent
infection working on a lot of things we
must utilize our nation's scientific
brilliance to vanquish the virus we have
to vanquish the virus as quickly as we
can because we have a lot of things
happening in this country and we have a
great future but we have to get back to
work this week the FDA established the
coroner virus treatment accelerator
program which is expediting the
development of new anti anti viral and
other therapies and they're doing it on
a very rapid basis and I think we're
having some very good results we'll tell
you about that HHS continues to speed
the development of therapies derived
from human blood that have the potential
to lessen the severe
or shorten the length of the illness and
as you know less Saturday the FDA also
gave emergency authorization for hydroxy
for chloroquine and the
hydroxychloroquine is a I hope it's
going to be a very important answer
we're having some very good things
happening with it and we're going to be
distributing it through the strategic
national stockpile it's going into the
strategic national stockpile to treat
certain patients and we have millions
and millions of doses of it twenty-nine
million to be exact in addition to that
we're making it and we're also getting
it from various other locations and
countries in one case I called Prime
Minister Modi of India this morning they
make large amounts of hydroxy
chloroquine very large amounts frankly
and I said they had a hold because you
know they have 1.5 billion people and
they think a lot of it and I said I'd
appreciate if they would release the
amounts that we ordered and they are
giving it serious consideration but they
do make India makes a lot of it but we
have already 29 million if you look at
me that's a big number
29 million doses we've got millions of
doses that are being made here and many
millions of doses that are made
elsewhere that are being shipped here
and it will be arriving we're just
hearing really positive stories and
we're continuing to collect the data but
I'll just speak for myself it's been out
for a long time it's a malaria drug it's
also a drug for lupus and there's a
there's a study out that people with
lupus aren't catching this horrible
virus or not they're not affected so
much by it now maybe that's correct
maybe it's false you're gonna have to
check it out but there's a lot of very
positive things happening with that
that's a game changer if that's the case
obviously we continue to work on the
vaccines but the vaccines have to be
down the road by probably 14 15 16
months we're doing great on the vaccines
I think Johnson & Johnson is leading
seems to be leading in terms of the
studies but we'll see what happens but I
feel good about that but that's down the
road but tremendous promise with with
what's just been mentioned in addition
to that Gilead Sciences has initiated a
Phase three let's down the line meaning
clinical studies of the drug remedy
severe now it's approximately 1,000
patients which is a pretty pretty good
study other drugs are also being studied
in patients and this week oracle great
company donated a new web portal Larry
Ellison amazing guy and platform to the
government to gather real-time data on
how patients are responding to the
various new treatments and they have a
very sophisticated site we'll be
learning a lot from Oracle and thank you
to them we're also spending economic
dollars like you wouldn't believe and
speeding economic relief to American
workers families and businesses
yesterday the Small Business
Administration launched the Paycheck
protection program to help employees
keep paying their workers in 24 hours
the Small Business Administration and
over 1,200 lending partners processed
over 28,000 loans it's so far ahead of
schedule and billions and billions of
dollars it's worked out incredibly well
and I want to thank Bank of America and
JPMorgan Chase and a lot of the big
banks that have been involved in a lot
of the community banks community banks
have really jumped on it and it's so far
going way ahead of schedule
the SBA also clarified that faith based
stations including houses of worship are
eligible for the Paycheck protection
program that's great as well as the
economic injury disaster loan program
that you're familiar with on the same
terms as every other applicant if we run
out of funding for the employee
retention program I will immediately ask
Congress for more money this is money
that's really going directly to the
people that need it the small businesses
that need it and the workers that need
it finally I can because when we open we
want to open strong with businesses that
are going remember we had the greatest
economy in the world and then one day we
were told you got to shut it down stop
it tell everyone to stay home because of
this horrible virus and we did that and
we did the right thing but now we have
to open we have to open our country
finally I can report that as of today
the State Department has successfully
coordinated the safe return of more than
40,000 Americans stuck abroad in over
400 flights from 75 countries many of
those countries were terrific in helping
us and I appreciate that very much
some of them I had to call the leaders
of the country most of whom I know and
once I did they snapped like you
wouldn't believe they really helped us
great so I appreciate that so we brought
back 40,000 Americans who were literally
stuck in some countries with no chance
of getting out we got them back 400
flights 75 countries think of that and
those countries in almost every instance
had a big problem with the virus I want
to thank the American people most of all
for the selfless sacrifices that they're
making for our nation I know it's not
pleasant although some people have said
they've gotten to know their family
better and they love their family more
than ever that's a beautiful thing
they've actually gotten to know them
they were in the same house with their
family for a long time I guess you can
also work the other way perhaps but we
don't want to talk about that and I want
to encourage everyone to keep following
our guidelines on slowing the spread
sustaining this war effort is and that's
what it is is a war effort
is the patriotic duty of every citizen
while we may be more physically distant
for a time we're closer together in the
heart and in the spirit and through this
great national unity is happening we're
having a great unity developing that a
lot of people didn't think would be
possible to develop like this and we
will conquer the disease and restore our
nation to its full and glorious might
and we're doing really well in a very
proud of everybody out there we're very
proud of you
it's something that nobody could have
ever projected it's been over a hundred
years that a thing like this has
happened and the problem with this one
is the contagion it's so contagious
nobody's ever seen anything like that
where it's so contagious you can be feet
away and just talking to somebody and
catch it you can catch it you know how
long it can live on surfaces so things
that nobody even thought of the level of
contagion so we're getting there we're
gonna make sure that it's over soon and
just keep going it's not going to be
long and thank you very much and with
that I'd like to ask dr. Hahn to speak
and he's been doing yeoman's work at the
FDA thank you very much doctor thank you
thank you thank you mr. president I'm
going to speak about hydroxychloroquine
and the efforts around that just preface
I'd like to echo what the president said
about the American people and the
resiliency and the just terrific work
mitigation is such an important part of
our fight against the Koba 19 virus last
week as the president said we issued an
emergency use authorization to allow the
donated hydroxychloroquine to come into
the country and enter the general
circulation we are prioritizing this
drug to come in for clinical trials also
into general use for physicians because
as you know physicians based upon their
interaction with the patient's their
assessment of the risks and benefits can
write a prescription for
hydroxychloroquine if they think it's
appropriate for the patient
being a physician we do this all the
time and that assessment needs to be
done between a patient and a doctor
and then the third portion is we wanted
to make sure that these drugs were in
the circulation in the in the supply
chain so that people who have them or
need them for the other indications
lupus rheumatoid arthritis had them
available so that was the purpose of the
emergency use authorization one other
thing I'd like to mention is that we on
Friday stood up a formal convalescent
plasma program we have a great deal of
enthusiasm for that there are some
reports that this is a benefit to
patients in other countries who have had
the koba 19:00 virus and what this means
is taking plasma from patients who've
had the virus and who have recovered and
transferring the immunity the
immunoglobulins if you will at the
immunity from that person to someone's
who sick and we're hopefully expanding
that across the country the Red Cross is
involved in that program and I think it
shows a great promise it needs to be
studied like other things but just like
I said before it provides hope we don't
want to provide false hope but
definitely hope thank you thank you very
much mr. president I'd like to just take
a couple of moments to talk a little bit
about the public health aspects and how
it relates to what the president just
said about the need for us to begin to
at least think about returning to some
degree of normality and that has to do
with what's gonna be happening as we end
this week and we go into next week you
will be seeing and we should not be
surprised because the kinetics of how
this virus works is that we're gonna be
seeing that they're gonna be deaths that
are going to continue to go up but as I
mentioned to this group and to the
general public multiple times there
really is a cascading of events where
you have new cases hospitalizations
intensive care and deaths so at the same
time that we may be seeing an increase
in deaths we want to focus on the
effective mitigation is really the
number of new cases and that's what
we're gonna be thinking about and
looking about so we're gonna pay close
attention to that and hopefully the
kinds of mitigations that we're talking
about are gonna have the impact to a
was to begin to think about maybe
changing a bit so the question arises is
is the mitigation working
so let's look historically and then they
just look at the reality of it clearly
in the countries China included that
I've implemented that since very strict
kinds of programs of mitigation clearly
it works in our own country we've seen
indication of that in Washington
remember Washington state was the first
to get hit but they put in a really good
program of mitigation and if you look at
the charts that dr. Berg's show the
other day they're still down they're
doing well and the reason is again what
I've said before but I think it's worth
reiterating that we have two opposing
forces here the virus which is wants to
do with the virus wants to do viruses
transmitted from people to people when
people are separated from each other
virus does not transmit it doesn't go
anywhere and that's the reason why
something as simple as the physical
separations because if you look at the
vice-president's chart that he shows all
the time here from this podium every
aspect of that ending the COBIT outbreak
in 30 days has some aspect of it a
physical separation whether that's
avoiding crowds whether that's staying
six feet away from people whether that's
doing teleworking all of it does that
that's our most important tool we'll be
talking about vaccines and drugs and
things like that that will mitigate
later but this is what we really have to
do and I want to I want to actually just
plea as I do multiple times from here to
the American public you know as sobering
and as difficult as this is what we are
doing is making a difference so we
really need to continue to do that I
must tell you I was just mentioning to
the vice president as we came in last
night when I wasn't here I went out with
my wife and actually did a little pal
walking down Massachusetts Avenue for
those who live in Washington know what
I'm talking about
and we passed a couple of restaurants
with people but getting takeout food the
restaurants were closed to people going
in but they were open to take out and I
saw something that absolutely
made me feel really really good they
were separating themselves by at least
six feet in fact some of the restaurants
had little things on the floor that said
stand here and then stand there and I
think if we as a nation pull together to
do that hopefully when we keep coming
back here at these press conferences
we'll be able to show you that that
curve that we keep talking about is
going in the right direction and if they
happen to answer questions later thank
you okay please you said over here that
the virus is springing up in areas you
did not expect yesterday you said some
states in the country are not in
jeopardy the fact that this is
unpredictable isn't that an argument for
every state to have one look there are
some states that are you have great
distance natural distance big land few
people and they're in very good shape
and if there is a case they can
quarantine that person or that person
will be separated will be brought to a
hospital secure area so you do have
different cases as opposed to a New York
or Los Angeles Los Angeles is doing
incredibly well by the way but areas we
have lots of people tight together it's
a big difference so no it's a they're
different there are many different cases
please thousand troops go into New York
and then are we expecting other fast
deployments or is it just armies yes
many of the places are really in great
shape there and there really have done a
fantastic job and we may add to the
thousand but New York will be getting
about a thousand military people nurses
doctors lots of other people because
it's within a drug that's medical no no
medical military medical military please
sir you twit earlier today that you like
the idea of a second crop ours task
force that was focused on reopening
thinking about so I was wondering if you
were planning to go forward with that
thinking about getting a group of people
and we have to open our country you know
I I had an expression the Cure can't be
worse than the problem itself right I
started by saying that and I continue to
say it
the cure cannot be worse than the
problem itself we got to get our country
openers did you say you'd like to see
arenas in absolutely I want fans back in
the arenas I think it's I think it's
know like whenever we're ready I mean as
soon as we can obviously and the fans
want to be back to you know they want to
see basketball and baseball and football
and hockey they want to see their sports
they want to go out onto the golf
courses and breathe nice clean beautiful
fresh air know that but I think it's
gonna be sooner rather than later but
and you know we're not gonna have to
have separation for the rest of our
times on the planet we need it for this
period of time but eventually people are
going to be able to occupy those seats
and arenas next to each other
like we have for all of my life and all
of your life
they want to sit next to each other at
restaurants they don't want to be you
know six feet away and yeah some
restaurant man called up he said yeah
I'm worried because I have a small
restaurant with not too many seats I
think you said 120 and he said if I
practice what this is I'm down to 30
seats I can't make it I said don't worry
about it that's for a short period of
time you'll be back to your number of
seats we can't do that otherwise you're
making everything that means your
stadium is half the size of what it was
a month ago no no they're gonna be close
together but they're gonna be breathing
air that's not infected that's not going
to kill people please I'm not committing
to it I'm not committing to it we're
gonna see where we are that'd be great
if we could but we're gonna be back to
good health soon in my opinion we're
making a lot of progress and we're
making progress because as Tony told the
story about the restaurant and about how
they were separated sort of
automatically people are doing that
people are doing that this thing in
their homes they don't want to go out
there doing what they know is the right
thing to do it's it's not very
complicated it's in many ways it's a
very big
four things you see yeah we have no
contingency plan we're having the
convention at the end of August and we
think by the end of August we'll be in
good shape
we have no contingency you know it's
going to be in North Carolina you know
and Charlotte and I think we're gonna
have a great convention I noticed I
think we had an opponent but I I almost
didn't know who it was he got point zero
zero zero zero one percent of the vote
but I heard he dropped out three or four
weeks ago I'm not sure maybe you could
tell me that's the kind of opponent I
had and hopefully we have another one
just like that in Joe packages what was
not in the stimulus package that you
signed last week
you would like well I think we're gonna
need more money for the small business
as it's been working out so well it's
been so efficient the banks have been
doing an incredible job I think we're
gonna need more money there I think yeah
we'll see but based on the first the
first couple of days it's been
incredible I think that restaurants and
entertainment that would be include
sports leagues all forms of
entertainment go back to the original
where they get tax deductibility for
what they're doing and for people come
in and buy tickets or go out for meals
and corporations can then send people in
to these restaurants who are gonna have
a hard time otherwise opening in my
opinion and that could be the same for
the sports leagues so we want to see for
entertainment and for restaurants
deductibility so that corporations can
take a deduction they'll send their
executives they'll send people there and
they get a deduction that is something
that will really bring life back to the
restaurants I think make them hotter
than before you know they used to have
it and when they ended it it was really
never the same it was never the same
yeah you said that you want to see as
few lives lost as possible and
but there are still eight governors all
Republicans who have refused to issue
these statewide stay at home workers
your own experts including dr. fowey
have said stay at home orders are the
most effective way to stop the spread of
this virus so so why not do everything
possible and Tennessee just right now
yeah do that we have a thing called the
Constitution which I cherish number one
number two those governors I know every
one of them they're doing a great job
they're being very very successful in
what they are doing and as you know I
want the governors to be running things
now in some cases will supersede but in
this case it's not I think it depends it
depends on the individual state that
you're talking about but they're doing
very well and they're doing a
magnificent job in running their states
1,700 cases right now coronavirus Utah
has 1255 I mean are these not states
that you think should have well that's a
very small number relative to
populations larger than some states that
do have stay at home it's up to the if I
saw something wrong if I saw a massive
breakout of which that's not I would
come down very hard but no not in that
case but in the case I know the states
are talking about by the way I think
you're up to 92% is covered 92% of the
country is covered and from a
constitutional standpoint they made the
difference they called the shots yes
Jeff good you and the others here are
saying people need to continue following
the mitigation efforts but you're also
saying again the Cure must not be worse
than the problem which is it no I'm just
saying we have to get this country open
Jeff it has to get open this country was
not designed to be closed so we have the
greatest we've ever had and then we're
paying people to stay home we'll think
of it we're paying people not to go to
work how about that how does that play
and they want to go to work by the way
they don't even want they don't want
money
this country is great but we're paying
people we have to get back to work
that's what I'm saying
go ahead place on topic go it's about
the announcement from last night it's a
yes I've been a question
not that we expect the answer to be yes
or no but was it Michael Atkinson doing
the job of the Inspector General of the
intelligence community the job he was
supposed to do what he simply took the
whistleblower complaint to Congress and
what hadn't been taken previously wasn't
he doing the job that he was supposed to
do that American taxpayers were paying
him to do and why did you decide to try
thought he did a terrible job absolutely
terrible
he took a whistleblower report which
turned out to be a fake report it was
fake it was totally wrong it was about
my conversation with the president of
Ukraine he took a fake report and he
brought it to Congress with an emergency
okay not a big Trump fan that I can tell
you instead of saying and we offered
this to him no no we will take the
conversation we're fortunately where
that transcript put in have a transcript
with the kind of deception and
dishonesty that were practiced by the
Democrats I might not be standing here
right now okay
fortunately we had a transcript and it
was a perfect transcript because even
the lieutenant colonel admitted it was
correct okay wait a minute wintermen yes
the question so he took this
whistleblower and I keep saying where's
the whistleblower right and why was the
whistleblower allowed to do this why was
he allowed to be you call a fraudulent
or incorrect transcript so we offered
this IG I don't know him I don't think I
ever met him I don't think I he never
even came in to see me how can you do
that without seeing the person never
came in to see me never requested to see
me he took this terrible inaccurate
whistleblower report right and he
brought it to Congress we offered to
have him see my exact conversation it
was all about the conversation by the
way that was the whole thing was about
the conversation right and then after we
saw it he must have said well because as
I've said it many times and it drives
you people crazy it was a perfect
conversation so instead of going and
saying gee
this is a terrible thing he said about
the president's conversation well it was
a fraud I didn't say that and by the way
you have the whistleblower where's the
informer right and here's another
question remember before I did the
before I gave the transcript in other
words before I revealed the real
conversation where's the second
whistleblower remember the second was a
wet wait wait wait there was gonna be a
second whistleblower but after I gave
the conversation he just went away he
miraculously went away where's the
informer because there was going to be
this Informer maybe Schiff was the
informer you ever think of that he's a
corrupt guys corrupt politician so
listen I say this where's the informer
remember the informer was coming forward
but I gave because see I did one thing
that surprised everybody this gentleman
right here said boy that was a shocker I
revealed the conversation I got approval
from Ukraine because I didn't want to do
it without their approval and they said
absolutely you did nothing wrong by the
way president of Ukraine foreign
minister said he did nothing wrong and
over that with 196 to nothing vote by
the Republicans that one dissenting
Republican vote dishonest Democrats
impeached a President of the United
States that man is a disgrace to I geez
alright let's go next please he's a
total disgrace did you run by your
decision to dismiss the inspector
general fine I will get off this because
people want to talk about what we're
talking about but let me just tell you
something that's my decision I have the
absolute right even the fake news last
night said he has the absolute right to
do it but ask him why didn't you go and
see the actual conversation there was no
rush he said all we have to rush it he
even said it was politically biased he
actually said that the report could have
been you know who the whistleblower is
and so do you and so does everybody in
this room and so do i everybody knows
but they give this whistleblower a
status that he doesn't deserve
he's a fake whistleblower and frankly
somebody oughta sue his ass off alright
it's enough of the whistle
go ahead a thousand of them from the
Chinese government are you concerned
what he didn't say is he okay let me
tell you what he didn't say two very
good friends of mine brought him those
whistle brought him those as ventilators
right two very good friends amok they
brought him if you'd like their name
I'll give you their name no but he the
governor didn't mention that it came
through the Chinese the country of China
but they were given by two friends of
mine but he didn't tell you that now the
governor also you'll see when you read
the letter the governor also asked for
40,000 40,000 he wanted 40,000
Friendly's now the governor as you know
had a chance to get sixteen thousand a
few years ago he decided not to get that
the state of New York has asked for help
I've given for hospitals for medical
centers then I gave him an additional
hospital then I gave him military people
to operate the hospital they were not
supposed to be qoph at hospitals the
boat the ship is not interesting thing
happened with the ship people aren't in
accidents because there's nobody driving
there's nobody taking motorcycle rides
down the West Side Highway at 100 miles
an hour people are away so people aren't
being injured now they're asking whether
or not we could open up the ship for
kovat we have given the governor of New
York more than anybody has ever been
given in a long time I'll just say I was
gonna say in history but in a long time
and I think he's happy but I think that
because I watched what he said today and
it was fine I wouldn't say gracious it
wasn't gracious it was okay I must tell
you Gavin Newsom has been gracious Los
Angeles California with the job we've
done and all of California it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter but I think
when we've given as much as we've given
to New York somebody should say nice
I'll tell you who's been very nice mayor
de Blasio has been very nice he
understands what we've given him we
brought him some more ventilators to
yesterday but nobody has been given like
New York
and I think I know he appreciates it
he just can't quite get the words out
but that's okay which one is on
mitigation on the reproductive and
Valium
what the virus the w-h-o had I think to
22.6 others had a percentage point or
two higher do we have a new number now
based on those mitigation techniques
have we noted to bring it down well I
think maybe you should answer that right
dr. Burks please you know it's an it's
an excellent question and it's why all
of the modelers and I really want to
thank them again they're reading all of
their models in light of the level of
the impact of the mitigation remember
none of us had really been through this
before so when we modeled school
closures and distancing and staying at
home and all of these pieces that had
never really come into the model before
they're working on that very diligently
now of course just to be clear we won't
know how valid the models are until we
move all the way through the epidemic
what we're trying you'll ating right now
and instead of working on are not we're
looking at testing and triangulating
testing tests positive cases
hospitalizations ICUs and the whole and
the course the recoveries because that's
also very important to us I think it's
very important that the American people
know that there are equal number of
states with less than 5% positives
despite high levels of testing so there
are states that are mitigating and
making this work they're also the states
that you know of the 18 states that have
the larger outbreaks and we're watching
them very carefully triangulating for
them all of the information to ensure
that clients who come to the hospital
are cared for and then their states in
the middle that we're trying to figure
out are they changing or not each of
those states and each of those epidemics
within those states may have a different
R value
and that is what we're trying to figure
out an independent it's very variable on
each of these factors but the bottom
line is and I think going into this
weekend it's really important for the
American people to to know this Spain
and Italy are moving through this they
are seeing their number of cases drop
they're seeing the number of people in
hospitals drop we are about on our
models and on the actual data about 12
days behind them at the same time we see
in the United States really good case
studies of the impact at Washington
state of California and then a series of
smaller states where we're trying to
learn from them how to do surveillance
and with these new HHS Abbott ID now
kits and I just want to thank Admiral
girar for getting them out being able to
look at testing in a more comprehensive
way so we can be doing surveillance and
mitigation simultaneously so we can
answer that very question it's going to
be very difficult to answer at this
moment across the United States because
each Metro cluster is on a different
pathway as they move through move
through the epidemic and I think we just
really ought to emphasize through
because we see Italy we see Spain moving
through and we hope to be in that same
position at the same time as the
president said he's concerned about
every single person that is succumbing
to this virus we all are and that's why
we're making sure that in this
triangulation they're tracking minute by
minute when we say FEMA and HHS is
tracking minute by minute the ventilator
Hospital and ICU bed need that's exactly
what's happening and also being flexible
and responsive to have DoD take a
thousand health care providers out of
there Medical Corps is a very big deal I
was in the Medical Corps for 29 years we
never did that so this is saying we
respect and understand the importance
and value of the American lives and
doing that but the our values will be
variable by state
you had breaking news last night you
know that you saw that where I think the
probable presidential candidate for the
Democrats will be Joe Biden and he
agreed that I was correct when I stopped
people from China very early very very
early from coming into our country and
doctor foul she said that was a very big
moment because it would be a much
different picture we have right now had
will add thousands and thousands of
people from the specific area I don't
have to go into it from China to come in
highly infected it would have been a
very different thing the other thing so
I appreciate the fact that he did
because I was called xenophobic racist I
was called many things when I did that
very early and I got a lot of credit for
it in the Federalist because the
Federalists covered the whole journey
and they said Trump was I didn't speak
to the author respected author they said
Trump was right at every single move and
on top of that he was going through a
fake impeachment a hoax I was going
through a hoax when I made the decision
and that does take a little time and
certainly a little thinking time but I
appreciated the fact that Joe Biden
announced last night that he now agrees
that I was correct you saw the report
come out that I was correct when I
stopped people from China coming in at a
very early date
we talked about the captain Crozier of
the USS which one what captain Crozier
that who is removed captain was removed
as the commander of the USS Burger I
don't know if you saw the videos of
sailors cheering for him as he left our
reporting shows that some sailors have
said that they are worried to reenlist
because they are not convinced that
commanders are taking care of their
health and taking care of them yeah okay
what do you say - I don't know much
about it I can only tell you this here
we have one of the greatest here we have
one of the greatest ships in the world
nuclear aircraft carrier credible ship
with thousands and thousands of people
and you had about a hundred and twenty
that were infected now I guess the
captain stopped in Vietnam and people
got off in Vietnam perhaps you don't do
that in the middle of a pandemic or or
something that looked like he was going
to be you know history would say you
don't necessarily stop and let your UC
elders get off number one but more
importantly he wrote a letter the letter
was a five-page letter from a captain
and the letter was all over the place
that's not appropriate I don't think
that's appropriate and these are tough
people these are tough strong people I
thought it looked terrible to be honest
with you now they made their decision I
didn't make the decision Secretary of
Defense was involved and a lot of people
were involved I thought it was terrible
what he did to write a letter I mean
this isn't a class on literature this is
a captain of a massive ship that's
nuclear-powered and he shouldn't be
talking that way in a letter he could
call and ask and suggest but he stopped
in Vietnam a lot of people got off the
boat they came back and they had
infection and I thought it was
inappropriate for the captain of a ship
to do I don't want to comment as to
whether or not but I agree with their
decision 100% in the back was Joe Barton
actually just attack
I've seen it he just would attack to you
you just say he didn't write anything
look he has people he has professionals
from the Democrats let me just read what
he said he said Donald Trump is not
responsible for the corona virus but he
is responsible for failing to prepare
our nation to respond to it how do you
do that he didn't write that that was
done by a Democrat operative he doesn't
write he doesn't he's probably not even
watching right now and if he is he
doesn't understand what he's watching
but just so you understand
it was very nice what they wrote I don't
know you know they release it at a
strange time you know sort of a strange
time to release something like that but
he admitted I was right and if you read
the Federalist story which most of you
won't because you don't want to but
you'd learn something because if you
goes to a chart times I was early dr.
Fauci I think I don't think he's changed
his mind but he said it was a very
important step when we stopped China
from coming in from the specific area
that was heavily infected would have a
whole different thing right now so I
don't really know what Joe Biden said I
know we care and again I see every once
in a while I'll say something I'll make
a speech and then it'll be critiqued and
I'll get this beautiful brilliant
critique Joe Biden didn't write that Joe
Biden didn't write that he wished he did
but he didn't yes we do I mean one of
the things that obviously is parallel
with thinking about the possibility as I
mentioned a little while ago about
mitigation allowing us to turn the
corner very much on the front burner is
what happens when we do because the risk
of there being a resurgent is real so
what we need to do and I believe I said
this before but it's worth repeating
that what we need to have in place and
we will have that in place is that as
you then pull back you have to have the
capability of in a very pristine precise
way do the kind of containment when you
do see it because remember when you get
to mitigation
containment takes the vaccine because
you're just struggling to mitigate but
when you get it down you need to make
sure it doesn't research that will
require the ability to test to identify
to isolate and to do contact tracing
that's what we have to have in place and
hopefully we will at the time that we
then pull back family members that's
working so this is a situation where
someone who's recovered from the virus
doesn't have the virus in their system
at all you can take plasma and this is a
pretty routine procedure you can
actually donate a couple times a week
couple times a month frankly and give
that plasma that plasma contains the
proteins in the blood that have the the
antibodies against the virus you can
take that process it and then give it to
someone who's ill and so that allows you
to transfer to immunity it doesn't have
to be matched by family or anything like
that since last Tuesday the Tuesday
before last we've allowed academic
centers and other laboratories and
hospitals around the country to do this
on a compassionate use basis what we did
was we pulled this together and what's
called an expanded access program and
run it through the Red Cross because
they've got the greatest system and
capacity for doing this and this allows
us to scale up so that when people get
sick we can actually have these donated
plasma packs and given to the patients
who are sick so we've started with the
Red Cross in this program we made an
announcement yesterday we are planning
to actually scale that up and we'll have
more information this week because we
want to make sure we have the systems in
place it's a superb question
three em right now Germany said that it
was an act of piracy that two hundred
thousand masks were apparently diverted
from Thailand
to the United States instead of to
Berlin is that a miscommunication did
that actually happen and should 3m be
fulfilling contracts we're very
disappointed in 3m they should be taking
care of our country and they can sell to
others but they should be taking our
care of our country the people that have
dealt with them have dealt successfully
with many companies over the last month
they don't like the way 3m has treated
our country they don't frankly like the
representatives of 3m and no active
Pratt you said piracy right piracy
there's been no act of piracy now if
there's been no act of piracy it's the
opposite 3m has not treated our country
well and if they do great and if they
don't they're gonna have a hell of a
price to pay
okay III say it that way and I watched
him on television on something talking
about how this could be so hard to
believe so hard to fathom they ought to
get their act together because I got
involved and I looked at what happened
and they have not 3m has not treated our
country well we'll get you the
information what is the question is that
what is the incidence of coronavirus
right now this is being looked at in a
Natural History study we don't have any
definitive information to be able to
make any comment that that it's an
obvious good question because it might
be a way for us to get some interesting
and potentially important data as to the
role of those medications but that's
something that is now being looked at
but we don't have any data to be able to
say that there definitively and I hope
they use the hydroxychloroquine and they
can also do it with z-pak subject to
your doctor's approval and all of that
but I hope they use it because I'll tell
you what
what do you have to lose in some cases
they're in bad shape what do you have to
lose it's been out there for a long time
and I hope they use it and they're gonna
look at the with doctors work with
doctors get what you have to get but we
have it stockpiled and it's we have a
lot of it and we're getting more of it
and as I told you I spoke to Prime
Minister Modi we're getting more of it
but we have a lot of it and I hope they
use it because it's been used for a long
time and therefore it's passed the
safety test FDA has been terrific dr.
Han I appreciate it very much too but
I've seen some results now it's early
yes it's early but and you should they
should look at the Lupus thing I don't
know what it says but there's a rumor
out there that because it takes care of
lupus very effectively as I understand
it it's a you know a drug that's used
for lupus so there's a study out there
that says people that have lupus haven't
been catching this virus No maybe it's
true maybe it's not why don't you
investigate that and there's also other
studies you know with the malaria that
the malaria countries have very little
people that take this drug for malaria
which is very effective for malaria that
those countries have very little of this
virus I don't know you're gonna check it
out but I think people should if it were
me in fact I might do it anyway I may
take it okay I may take it and I'll have
to ask my doctors about that but I may
take it yeah please go ahead
look I've been against OPEC all my life
because what is it it's an illegal you
could call it a cartel you could call it
a monopoly use a lot of different names
for it but it broke down very violently
very violently so I don't care about
OPEC I really don't I couldn't care less
about okay let me just say no no I think
they're gonna settle it you know why
because they're going to be destroyed
they're destroying themselves if they
don't Russia two very important and we
had a very good conversation present
putting on myself very good but Russia's
a big part of their economic well-being
is from oil well oil is that a record
look nobody has ever seen anything like
it it's actually lower than you even
think
and it's to their advantage obviously
it's Sisodia Arabia's advantage they
told me they're discussing Saudi Arabia
went much further than that he thinks
that a deal is going to be made at 10
million barrels reduction and maybe more
than that he actually indicated it would
most likely be much more than that so
we'll see what happens
I mean we're gonna see what happens but
as far as OPEC is concerned I mean I was
against OPEC for years and years because
I thought it was very unfair to our
country the beautiful thing is we have
built one of the great you know one of
the things we've done is created so much
we we produce with the number one
producer in the world right now I don't
like it for a different reason because
it's going to hurt a lot of jobs in our
country this price it's gonna hurt a lot
of jobs now with all of that being said
people are going to be driving paying
ninety cents a gallon did you ever hear
that what's at nineteen fifty two or
something alright so from that
standpoint but you know what I am a big
believer in our great energy business
and we're gonna take care of our energy
business and if I have to do tariffs so
an oil coming from outside or if I have
to do something to protect or thousands
and tens of thousands of energy workers
and our great companies that produce all
these jobs I'll do whatever I have to do
ok yeah ma'am go ahead a little while
ago about
right now but I'm wondering if you're
willing to share about your youngest son
and how he's dealing with life and
sheltering in place not going to school
those words well he was a good athlete
and he loves soccer and he he's like
everyone else I mean everything shut
down he's in his room he's happy but
he's not as happy as it could be he'd
like to be playing sports barren and
let's see what happens but we have to
get back we have to get back remember
that we have to get back and we have to
get back soon you guys ever stop you
want to keep going for a little while
huh I mean do you ever stop how many
times yes and in many cases it's the
same actually a lot of good questions go
ahead but keep going yes so you're not
gonna blame me that I kept it going too
long people said all we kept every time
you'll ask it no I mean no it's amazing
okay every can't wind up I thought we've
gone through the roof every I think
every single hand went up the last time
you know what it shows you it shows you
that you love what you do go ahead you
do know you're doing some of you do it
well not all of you go ahead I'm not
looking at you by the way get the job
supports numbers yesterday obviously
that's kind of a small portion cuz it's
like the first half of March was there
anything in there that was any sign of
optimism obviously we all saw the
numbers in down a retail go is there
anything you said okay maybe with the
spires we will see the job numbers or
what they are we asked everybody to go
home don't work so the numbers are gonna
be you know astronomical we understand
that I understood that I know somebody
said that me numbers are meaningless and
then they took that to me no jobs don't
mean anything and you know it was just
another fake news story it wasn't me
that said it why there was a very smart
person but they meant it by saying it
really is what that's why I answer your
question very carefully the numbers are
what they are we know the numbers were
going to be massive because we told
everybody to go home and a lot
door essentially right don't come to
work you can't come to work don't go
outside don't breathe don't do anything
we can open up our country but I know I
know that it's coming back and in my
opinion it will come back very strong
there's a tremendous energy there's a
tremendous demand and some good things
have happened I mean I don't know you
know there's one habit that as you know
most of you a lot of you have covered me
a long time before I did this I was
never a big believer in shaking hands
but I decided if you don't shake hands
you're not gonna be winning a lot of
contests right now I'm not sure you have
to shake hands anymore a couple of
people have told me Debra you told me
that if we didn't shake hands the
incidents of flu flu is a big deal also
and that flu might be cut down in half
who knew that shaking hands was such a
bad thing I felt it I bet I always felt
it and you know I was never to a point
where I can't shake somebody's hand I
knew people like that too but there were
too many of them but when I ran for
office all of a sudden I'm shaking
hundreds of it and if I don't I wouldn't
even be standing here but I think that's
a custom that maybe people don't have to
we have to get close together we have to
sit together at the stadiums we have to
sit next to each other and wrestle all
that stuff is gonna happen but I think
the concept of shaking hands maybe is
something that's gonna be a little bit
from the past let's see what happens
maybe they'll go right back to shaking
hands good is there anything you want
people do to show their support
especially we have two doctors up there
to show their support for the medical
community is there something that we see
people clapping when nurses leave well
we've seen a lot of that yet you might
say something that I have seen such
support I said this morning where
everyone's it deep lapping for fire
department that cop in for peace but
they are really go these people are what
you know what they're like they're like
Tony they're like warriors Mike they're
like warriors they were going into
Elmhurst Hospital which has been tragic
right near where I grew up in Queens
going in and the people in buildings is
going I mean they're the rockstars
they're warriors nurses doctors
first responders what they're what
they're going through and they don't
even know what's gonna happen I mean
they go in and by the way even if they
have great equipment they're catching it
you know great it could have good
equipment they catch it they graduate
with good with bad it is evil but Tony
you might say something I'm Mike you may
see something say something about that
yeah I'm glad you brought up that
question because I don't think people
can really fully appreciate the
extraordinary effort of these people I
mean it's it's it's amazing I you know I
did all of my medical training in New
York City in a big busy New York City
Hospital at a time when it was just what
you normally see in a hospital I came to
NIH and I spent about five to eight
years in the very early years of the
AIDS epidemic which was just the darkest
years of my life because almost every
single one of my patients died and yet
as we knew epidemiologically that there
was very little risk there was a small
risk but very little risk of getting
infected from a patient to see now what
these brave warriors are doing in the
hospitals not only giving life-saving
treatment to people but every single day
putting themselves at risk for
themselves and their family I just think
that the the American public
oh and phenomenal debt of gratitude for
these people and they should just salute
them at every every ways you can you
know when we were at war and at the
height of the war and Afghanistan and
Iraq when you're at an airport and you'd
see somebody with a uniform come by
everybody would do that I think that's
what we should do when we see health
care workers just support them
the stories are incredibly moving about
what health care workers are doing every
day it's not just that they're going
back into the hospital in places like
New York and New Jersey earlier than
that and in Washington State and
California where this first began it's
not just that they're providing care to
people but because of the nature of how
contagious
the corona virus is they're also
supplementing for family I mean that's
what that's what gets to me
when I hear the stories that
understandably in nursing homes and in
hospitals they're restricting visitors
and they should to prevent the spread of
the virus to be brought into the
hospital door to be brought out and so
to hear the stories of health care
workers who are holding up an iPhone
while someone who's critically ill with
the corona virus may well be saying
their last goodbyes to their family and
then to be there in those moments I mean
our health care workers are there not
just doctors and nurses today they
they're supplementing for family for
people all across the country and and I
just think you know tomorrow's Palm
Sunday
it's Holy Week and great Christian
tradition and I have people asked me
from time to time send me an email or on
this many conference calls that we have
they said what can we be praying about
and my first thought is with the
families who have lost loved ones and
the patients who are struggling with
coronavirus but during this very special
week I just encourage people to pray for
our health care workers pray for them
and their families they are really the
hands and feet everyday not just of
health care but of the heart of the
American people and we are all grateful
for them every hour of the day and think
also about the Army Corps of Engineers
that's a little different depending on
where they are and where they're working
but
the army-corps vegetal in New York City
2500 beds in three days and we think of
that and FEMA what they're doing and the
National Guard is now delivering for the
states because the states were unable to
get would drop it at a big warehouse
where we're told to drop it and the
states were unable some of the states
were unable to bring it from the
warehouse to the site so we got the
National Guard to become a delivery
service if you can believe it and they
would bring it and some of those sites
were dangerous sites they were very
dangerous sites think of that it's been
amazing it's been amazing I just think
I've never seen anything like it I'm so
proud of this country and and really
it's a world problem and some some
countries in the world are just handling
it so well you know again I keep saying
it's 151 that was as of two three days
ago it's probably more some people said
they didn't know there were that many
countries that's how big this is and
Mike said something else so yeah Palm
Sunday tomorrow think of it we're not
going to churches some Palm Sunday but
think of next Sunday Easter and I
brought it up before I said maybe we
could allow special for churches maybe
we could talk about it maybe we could
allow them with great separation outside
one Easter Sunday I don't know it's
something we should talk about but
somebody did say that well then you're
sort of opening it up to that little you
know do we want to take a chance on
doing that when we've been doing so well
but Easter Sunday Palm Sunday I'm gonna
be watching tomorrow live from Riverside
California great church but I'm gonna be
watching on a computer right on a laptop
I think on Easter maybe I'll be watching
from a laptop as opposed
so how sad is it that we have Easter pom
and Easter Sunday and people are
watching on laptops and computers it's
said but but the job that this whole
country is done is amazing but I'll say
this our medical professionals what
they've done
because they are they walk into those
hospitals you see them putting on their
gear and there they're putting in orders
they're walking through the front doors
and some of those people are gonna die
they're gonna die you know it's like
incredible and we could say what we want
Tony and Deb about young and medium aged
plenty of those people dying too you
know it's it generally hits the older
people where they have problems it hits
young people too and it hits middle-aged
people too but these people are walking
into hospitals and i watch i kid i think
it's it's incredible and they're putting
their out for them getting it and
they're going into going it's like it's
like a that it's like a war again
there's never been anything so
contagiousness in in 1917 it was vicious
if you got it but it wasn't contagious
like this now in 1917 had they had the
internet and all the means of
communication they could have practiced
distancing you know by the time people
started thinking in terms in those terms
they lost I guess seventy-five to a
hundred million people so that's modern
you know that's a modern-day great thing
that happened please body tests well I
don't know I'd rather leave that to the
doctor doctor do you have an answer to
that we think it'll be a tool to help us
get people back to work it'll be
additional information because as you
know if you have an antibody that means
you were exposed and have recovered from
it that with the information about
diagnosis should help this testing
determine on a large scale how many
people can go back to work have these 18
points so as you know a couple weeks ago
we provided a great deal of regulatory
flexibility around this a lot of great
developers have been working on this dr.
Burks put a call out to the academic
labs around the country to do this and
we've been working very closely with a
number of manufacturers so we think that
it can be scaled up relatively quickly
recent interview you had said that you
knew the guidance would not be enough I
wanted to ask your confidence level
about the 30-day guidance and whether
it'll be enough you know it's tough to
talk about levels of confidence but I
can tell you one thing that I feel
strongly that if we do in a very
proactive way what I said in my opening
comments and people literally across the
country as a baseline have that physical
separation and as we've mentioned up
here they'll be varying degrees of that
depending upon whether you're in New
York City or you're in a place that's
less but every place everybody should be
doing some degree of this physical
separation if we do that I again I have
confidence that what we will see is the
turning-around of the curve whether or
not it'll be all the way down what we
want it's impossible to say I would be I
would be foolish to say that but the one
thing I am confident in so let's take
this to the bank that mitigation works
so it does we've seen it in other
countries we've seen it in our own
country and that's the reason why I keep
coming up at every chance I get to play
with the American people to please take
a look at those guidelines that the
vice-president keeps putting up with his
chart because every single one of those
points has something to do with physical
separation but again we're not going to
destroy our country we have to get back
because you know at a certain point
you'll lose more people this way through
all of the problems caused then you will
with what we're doing right now what
we're doing right now
I think it's gonna be very successful
but you know what I don't know we're
gonna we have a big decision to make at
a certain point okay we have a big
decision to make
we want this extra period of time but I
said it from the beginning the Cure
cannot be worse than the problem itself
and we cannot let that happen
we have an incredible country we were
having the greatest period in our
country's history from an economic
standpoint in many other ways we cannot
let this continue so at a certain point
some hard decisions are gonna have to be
made go ahead brother
ventilator manufacturers are doubling
tripling even quadrupling their
production in some cases true and and
yet medical experts and some of these
manufacturers are predicting that there
will still be shortages of tens of
thousands of ventilators is it time for
you to level with the American public
that there likely will be shortages of
ventilators in some cases it could be I
mean it could be you have shortages and
it could also be that you have some that
have way overestimated the number of
ventilators they need we think that you
know we have a good a good amount ready
to move I mean literally like an army
they're ready to move to any hot spot
but some of the ones that you're talking
about always a nasty question from CNN
but some of the ones yeah because I
think that frankly you know because you
know what you've asked that question
about 10 times over the course of about
a month
look we're mobilized and ready to go we
have a lot of ventilators ready to go
and if we had given them all out we
wouldn't and you would be over stocked
in many areas what we're doing is we
have a very good plan to take from some
areas even though we have the 10 or
almost the 10,000 we're also taking from
areas that won't be as badly hit as
today we think they will be there will
be some areas hit harder than we think
and there's nothing that Debra would
Tony or any of these professionals can
do about it this thing moves in a lot of
ways but what we're going to do is we
are going to have as and you look at us
compared to a lot of other countries
we're in much better shape but
if these professionals have done an
amazing job now over the next week in
two weeks it's gonna be a very very
deadly period unfortunately but we're
gonna make it so that we lose as few a
lives as possible and I think we're
gonna be successful I think we already
are successful in that regard when you
look at that graph and you see all of
the the bumps if you want to call it at
a very low level and you see a couple at
a higher level they were tough but you
see all of those levels you know when
you look at and when you hear about
Italy and then you hear about France and
then you have you know what we have is
we have many Italy's all over we have we
they're like countries California is a
country New York is a country if you
look at them from the standpoint of what
we're talking about we have many like
country spuds some are hot spots and
there's nothing we're gonna do about it
one of the biggest surprises is
Louisiana because it started off so good
and then all of a sudden it shot up like
a rocket but we are going to try and
have ventilators wherever we possibly
can Jeff go ahead some of these
companies to ramp up production as fast
as possible it still won't be enough
well New York one at 40,000 ventilators
okay 40,000 of what 40,000 does it's
like cars it's a big project it's a it's
an expensive product I mean some of them
a $50,000 apiece I saw one the other day
55,000 I was before they start playing
the games with supply and demand okay
some are very very become luxury some
are not but frankly these are very
expensive products these are very
high-tech projects and products and they
take a period of time we have thousands
of them being built right now some will
be ready and we're going to have extra
and we'll keep them at hospitals but a
lot of hospitals a lot of states had the
chance of getting ventilators and they
turn those ventilators down for so they
could spend their money at something
else and in a way I understand that
because who thinks a thing like this is
that it's not a knock if I'm told like
perhaps New York you can spend a billion
dollars on ventilators and get 16,000 or
a massive number of ventilators that
they've been offered over the years
or you can build a new bridge or road or
something I mean I understand how that
works I'm not blaming anybody I'm just
saying they a lot of the states had
chances of stockpiling a lot of
ventilators they didn't do it and I
think we're doing a very good job and
helping them out please yeah and it's a
very fair question I understand that
question very well yeah can you give us
a sense of perhaps dr. Burks of what
that means to America Lee I'd like to
ask also yeah I'd like to say we know
pretty much the line of attack we know
the numbers the numbers of the numbers
they seem to be checking out
unfortunately or in some cases you know
that they're on the low side which were
very happy we want to keep them in the
very low side and that's where we're
headed and I think that's maybe where
we're headed but I'd like to ask maybe
you and Tony what are what where is that
where is the the week or the number of
days of greatest attack what will be our
worst day if that's possible to
determine I think that's what you're
asking
so as you can look in the places that
are the most difficult hit right now the
Detroit area the New York area of
Louisiana area and we are doing it by
the counties in those states because
there are mostly its metro areas and the
bedroom communities around those metro
areas because people went to work and
got exposed and came home and I exposed
other if you look out in New York now
you see that it's in Long Island and
this out in Suffolk County an awesome
Nassau County all of those counties
Wayne and Oakland they're all on the up
side of their curve of mortality so you
know when you get to the peak you come
down the other side and one will the
people so by the predictions that are in
that health data org they're predicting
in those three hotspots all of them
hitting together in the next six to
seven days
you can go to the website it's variable
each one of those communities is
different but you know where New York is
how much their mortality has been and
you know what we're seeing today are the
people who were infected two or three
weeks ago
if mitigation in New York worked and we
believe it is working the cases are
gonna start to go down but the mortality
will be a lag behind that because of the
comorbidities and other conditions so
that's why all of the predictions are
that this next week and I think we said
this last Sunday when we talked about
the charts and it's difficult to and we
tried to prepare the American people to
understand that you have to as much as
you go up you have to come down the
other side because coming down is a
reflection of the cases that we're
coming in before I'd rather not say a
number but the numbers are available if
you go to the website I mean you can see
that there's several hundreds per day in
New York and I think Governor Cuomo has
talked about that increasing still into
the five six seven hundred range a day
so you know that's very concerning to us
we again applaud the healthcare workers
who are doing every single thing humanly
possible to save more lives and we are
ensuring on a ventilator by ventilator
day by day to get them there so that we
can say and we can be there when they
need it because we are supposed to be
that group that comes in after all of
the resources are exhausted and we have
really applauded what organ did and we
really applaud what the governor is
doing about moving between the states
between these different counties to
bring them to New York because that's
what's needed today a different place
will be needed tomorrow
but something apparently you said
yesterday that you had some concerns
about Pennsylvania Colorado and
Washington DC could you expand on that
we're watching them because they are
starting to go on that up side of the
curve we're hoping and believing that if
people mitigate strongly the work that
they did over the last two weeks will
blunt that curve and they won't have the
same upward slope and peak that New York
New Jersey Connecticut and part of Rhode
Island are having so this is a very
import the next two weeks are
extraordinarily important and that's why
I think you've heard from dr. Falchi
from myself from the president and the
vice president that this is the moment
to do everything that you can on the
presidential guidelines this is the
moment to not be going to the grocery
store not going to the pharmacy but
doing everything you can to keep your
family and your friends safe and that
means everybody doing the six-feet
distancing washing your hands so I mean
ditto to everything that dr. Berg said
but also to emphasize why it's so
important to do that because we're
looking at three or four really key
hotspots that are still going up it's
absolutely essential that the ones that
are down at that lower level that dr.
Burke showed the other day those
communities where they're still going up
we've got to make sure we don't have
multiple waves of Peaks that's gonna be
the answer to the question of when we
can start pulling back because if you
keep having multiple peaks and different
waves that's gonna make it very
difficult we put your foot on the
exactly what I said
just before and I keep repeating just
make sure everybody does the at least
the minimal amount of that physical
separation because the virus has no
place to go if you're physically
separated and one of the reasons that I
keep talking about hydroxychloroquine is
that the question that nobody ever asks
and the question that I most hate the
answer to
is what happens if you do have a
ventilator what are your chances and I
just hope that hydroxy cleric win-wins
coupled with perhaps the z-pak as we
call it dependent totally on your
doctors and the doctors there because
you know the answer to that question if
you do have the ventilator you know the
answer to that question and I hate
giving the answer so I don't want to get
them there I don't want to get them
there it is a possibility a possibility
and I say it what do you have to lose
I'll say to get what do you have to lose
take it I really think they should take
it but it's their choice and it's the
doctor's choice or the doctors in the
hospital but a hydroxychloroquine try it
if you'd like the other thing if you
have a heart condition I understand
probably you stay away from the z-pak
but that's an antibiotic it can clean
out the lungs the lungs are a point of
attack for this horrible virus but when
you have a ventilator don't ask the
answer because I hate it if you have it
and it's working beautifully I don't
like the answer because it's not a very
high percentage so I want to keep them
out of ventilators I want to keep them
if we if this drug works it will be not
a game-changer because that's not a nice
enough term it will be wonderful it'll
be so beautiful it'll be a gift from
heaven and it works because when people
go into those ventilators you know the
answers I know the answers and I'm glad
you don't write about it a mic please
but well you've heard from the experts
what our task force is heard that it's
going to be difficult week for the
American people you will see testing
increased around the country and so
cases are going to continue to rise
across America and before I give a few
facts relevant to an earlier question
about ventilators let me just let me add
my voice to what the president just said
and what all the physicians who spoken
has said even though we see the losses
rising in the days ahead do not be
discouraged because there is evidence
across the country that Americans have
been putting the social distancing and
mitigation into practice and it is
making a difference we are seeing it in
the canoe cases that are being reported
because remember people families that
experience loss up to this day and in
the next week have a loved one who
contracted the corona virus in most
cases more than two weeks ago in many
cases before social distancing and
mitigation efforts were put into effect
and so we want to encourage you believe
in the president's coronavirus
Guidelines for America go to coronavirus
gov print them off again put them on the
refrigerator and remind yourself to put
them into practice on the subject of
ventilators if I can amplify the point
the president made our team at FEMA is
doing a remarkable job working with
governor's state health officials and
local hospitals particularly focused on
our priority areas will prefer to the
New York metro area which includes a New
Jersey and
Connecticut we're focused on the New
Orleans metro area Louisiana we're
focusing on Detroit we're focusing on
Chicago these are the areas where we see
the significant rise in cases and we are
we are surging supplies specifically
ventilators but all personal protective
equipment from FEMA to those areas and
and just to give you a couple of
examples I spoke to governor's in New
York New Jersey Louisiana Massachusetts
Michigan and Maryland today
alone and in those cases Governor Cuomo
is actually assessing all of the
available ventilators we've sent 4400
ventilators already to New York as as
has already been referenced they're
going to receive a shipment of over a
thousand from overseas and and allow me
to say as I told her personally today
the governor of Oregon governor Kate
brown her unilateral decision to send
140 ventilators because Oregon they felt
Oregon today is in a place where they
could give those ventilators to New York
to me was in the very highest American
tradition of loving your neighbor and
when I talked to Governor Cuomo mr.
president he actually told me they never
asked Oregon for the ventilators and
Governor Brown hadn't even called him to
tell him that she was doing that it
really is remarkable when I talked to
Governor Hogan today and what President
I'll be speaking to all of America's
governor's on Monday again I I told him
how inspired I was and how we ought to
spread the word to other governors in
areas where they can where they can
spare resources to be joining with us at
the federal level and and providing them
to states at the point of the need but
just a few four instances as we track
New Jersey as I told Governor Phil
Murphy we deployed two hundred
ventilators to New Jersey today
Louisiana where we're monitoring
literally hour by hour what's taking
place in New Orleans with with some
encouraging news but still great
challenges yesterday you heard the
president say that we deployed 330
thousand gallons that
been delivered to the public health
systems and hospitals there 200
ventilators
I spoke to governor Charlie Baker today
and was able to inform him we're
watching Boston area very closely a
hundred ventilators are deploying today
I spoke to governor Gretchen Whitmer
today Detroit is experiencing a
significant number of cases we're
watching it carefully and today
FEMA directed 300 ventilators to
Michigan again as the president said
we're all working our hearts out but
what I want to say to American families
and what I want to say to health care
workers is that we are going to identify
the resources leave no stone unturned
and we are going to we are going to
focus resources on those areas in the
order that they emerge now the last
thought is back on mitigation we are
hoping that we do not see other major
cities in the country experience what
what Seattle experienced what Greater
New York City area is experiencing what
New Orleans experiencing and that's all
in the hands of the American people
today and so I just want to encourage
you can coronavirus go put into practice
the president's coronavirus guidelines
and you will do your part to save lives
protect the American people and ensure
that we will have the resources to meet
this moment wherever the need should
arise a lot of small business owners a
lot of concerns that what are they
get this money some say some of the
banks weren't ready yesterday to start
processing loans sometimes where
schedules the banks have been great JP
Morgan Chase Bank of America they're so
far ahead this is typical with you in
particular
we hear they're behind what they're not
behind it's been a flawless it's been
flawless so far far beyond our
expectations you should say I hear
you're doing well but maybe I don't even
hear of any glitch they've done billions
of dollars of loans to small business
and these are great loads these are
loans that get immediately paid off
these are loans that get businesses back
I wish you could answer ask a question
where something's working so well now
maybe things won't work well and I don't
mind that gun but where something's
working so well and you ask a question
in such a negative way it's doing great
yeah go ahead it's doing great really
good maybe it won't in two weeks and
I'll respond differently but it's doing
great you know it and so does everyone
else everyone's shocked how well it's
doing who did dr. Burks yes some
demographics such as seeing that men
might be more susceptible to the virus
seeing in Europe more cases between 30
and 50 US has the data that you've seen
in the past two weeks changed that
assessment are men more susceptible
wonder how to like a change meshes same
pattern same answer that we've given you
penniless both between 30 and 50 being
more adversely affected
no I tomorrow I'll bring you all the
grass we can bring an updated graph but
it's very similar case also be
restricting flights from hot spots well
we're looking at it very seriously right
now we're dealing with governors we're
dealing with airlines we're dealing with
a lot of different factors it's a very
difficult decision we're also doing
testing getting into planes very strong
testing states are doing testing of
people that leave planes because they
don't want to have people coming in who
are infected so understanding that and
the level of testing has been enormous
okay and some states are saying you have
to go in quarantine for two weeks
if you come from certain areas so
knowing that we're working with the
governor's some states are doing when
they land they're doing very strong very
powerful testing please go ahead okay
well did you check up again governments
are doing it to her government good one
last question on ventilators the
governor of New York said that he
received the nation in ventilators from
Jack kemah of Alibaba which I think is
your friend would you call on the
business community to donate ventilators
not necessary to Newark but others
Louisiana no Jack Ma is a friend of mine
and he's made it very possible to get
about a thousand ventilators from China
but that was from him and my other
friend that was really a gift and we
appreciate it very much it was very nice
of them all right I think we've had
enough we'll be seeing you very soon and
I'm sure that you know that all of us
are going to be working very hard we're
working very hard we are really coming
up into a time that's going to be very
horrendous probably a time like we
haven't seen in this country wouldn't
you say I mean I don't think we've seen
a time like this in the country and
we're getting to that at that point
where it's going to really be some very
bad numbers we want to keep those
numbers a lot lower than they would have
been and we will do that we have
tremendous talent working we have
tremendous people and that includes
governor's that includes everybody
everybody's working but unfortunately
we're getting to that time when the
numbers are gonna peak and it's not
going to be a good look in situation I
really believe we probably have never
seen anything like these kind of numbers
maybe during the war doors in a world
war a World War one or two or something
but this is a war all and to itself and
it's a it's a terrible thing we will be
seeing you soon we'll keep you totally
abreast we're also going to be releasing
new ventilator numbers because we have a
lot of them coming and a lot of them
going to